remember when President Obama was still
president and the right would concoct
these FEMA camp
conspiracy theories and I don't even
really remember the exact details
because they were so ridiculous but it
went something like Obama's going to
build a Fema camp it's gonna be like a
concentration camp or an internment camp
he's gonna put people in it he will
declare martial law and suspend future
elections and effectively crown himself
president for life as sort of a plan to
become a dictator or something like that
obviously none of that stuff happened
but the Trump administration is now
actually building a camp to concentrate
the kids that are being picked up by
Border Patrol coming into the United
States across the us-mexico border the
Department of Health and Human Services
is checking out Fort Bliss in Texas as a
place where they might be able to on
this massive army base build a tent city
to hold up to 5,000 kids according to US
officials whatever you thought about
President Obama this plan from the Trump
administration is way closer to a
concentration camp or an internment camp
than anything that President Obama even
proposed to do never mind actually did
and meanwhile the Trump administration
continues this completely immoral
practice of separating migrant children
from their parents so the child shelters
that exist are already overflowing and
just out of curiosity if you set up this
tent city and kids die there what
happens will it be pursued the way that
it should be pursued or will it be sort
of like that they were undocumented they
weren't here legally anyway and it'll
get brushed under the rug I think we
know which way it'll go and it's
absolutely disgusting now online
I see people already saying this is a
concentration camp I don't know right I
mean I don't know whether that's the
phrase that I would use but it certainly
is pretty close to an internment camp
and in a way it's Alex Jones conspiracy
about FEMA camps coming true except
they're military camps not FEMA camps
and they're under President Trump not
President Obama they are actually
building the
and they're doing it in a place that
regularly has temperatures over a
hundred degrees in the summer it's the
first half of June I looked today the
temperature at Fort Bliss was going to
be a high of 99 degrees and they are
building a tent city to house little
kids this is the dystopia that we were
warned about 5,000 children without
their parents in a camp in a illegally
I guess we'll call it legal limbo will
there be social workers if you're gonna
have 5,000 kids you probably should have
at least 150 social workers to
adequately care for these children are
they planning to have 150 social workers
at the camp unclear and what I want to
know is what will it take for people to
cross party lines and just say this
can't happen we can't allow this to
happen because your dollars are funding
this your tax dollars my tax dollars are
funding this and in the end it's
effectively an internment camp for
little kids yeah I wonder if they'll
draw the same sense of urgency or
contempt maybe as they did for the
Japanese internment camps which I think
you can draw an analogy to certainly
these children aren't American citizens
like many of the Japanese people were
yeah but it's just as urgent I mean when
you're talking about kids what does that
matter so much you know what's scary
about that there was wholesale
indifference to the japanese-american
internment camps so if we are actually
if we want to figure out will there be
an a demand for action and outrage here
if we look back at what the attitude was
during World War two and the
japanese-american internment calves
doesn't bode well for us doesn't bode
well for us at all these are kids who
are not free to go
the military is controlling the space
and this is the type of thing that any
reasonable human rights organization
would say you're violating people's
basic human rights full stock yeah just
as the Japanese were seen as enemies at
the time Hispanics are now and so people
won't really care so much even though
you're dealing with kids here the
rhetoric from the current administration
has authorized these kids in a way that
they are indeed seen not necessarily as
enemies
but I would agree people that don't
really deserve the exact same care that
we would give to Americans